[Musique]
on a procédé enfin les services
d'enquête ont procédé à des
géolocalisations avec des drones et ils
ont
répertorié une soixantaine de sites qui
pouvaient potentiellement recueillir des
cavités
donc un premier travail en amont a été
fait pour pour déterminer les cavités
qui pouvaient qui pouvaient être
intéressantes parfois on a des arts
posés à l'endroit enfin etc donc il en
reste il en reste une trentaine et voilà
donc elles sont elles sont exploitées
explorées pendant deux jours deux ou
trois jours de toute façon le périmètre
est en fait on avait déjà
fouillé un périmètre assez important
donc on a étendu le périmètre un peu
au-delà parce que les souvenirs de
Monique Olivier sur sur 20 ans étaient
un peu
manqué de précision on va dire donc on a
un endroit on a une montée et
donc voilà il fallait un peu plus loin
puisqu'on a pas réussi à trouver le camp
de la victime donc on a étendu la zone
de recherche un peu plus loin donc elle
est là pour voir si par rapport aux
endroits où on fouille des choses
peuvent vivre comme d'habitude
dans cette zone là donc 20 ans plus tard
est-ce que
la probabilité de retrouver le camp
d'Estelle mouzins existe ou pas on peut
retrouver des traces du corps je pense
mais retrouver le corps complètement ça
me paraît difficile et puis nous sommes
sur le terrain avec Monique Olivia on le
parcours on essayant de raviver ses
souvenirs
ou qu'elle nous dise qu'elle sait sur la
distance entre cet endroit et l'endroit
où la les venus avec Michel Fourniret
sur le chemin qu'elle a parcouru sur
l'emplacement où il pouvait se trouver
c'est donc
ces questions qui lui sont posées de
manière incessante pour essayer de
trouver un détail qui me permet
d'identifier l'endroit où Michel
Fourniret enterré Estelle la famille
d'Estelle souhaite que la faire soit
rapidement jugé
elle est heureuse que ses fouilles
soient faites elle en remercie les
enquêteurs les magistrats mais elle
souhaite aussi que à un moment donné
justice soit rendu et donc
on est
on a plus le temps c'est ce qu'on dit à
Monique Olivier aujourd'hui il faut
qu'elle dise qu'elle nous aide ce
qu'elle ne fait pas pour le moment